(siren blaring)
(BuzzFeed sound effect)
(easy listening flute music)
- Everybody get down on the ground!
Right now, get down!
Down!
Fill my bag, put the money in the bag.
(easy listening flute music)
(footsteps)
- Hello, my name is
Officer Holden Whodoneit,
in the court of law, decisions
of lasting reprocussion
are often made based solely
on eyewitness accounts.
From this point on, I'd
like you to rely solely
on your own memory.
For the sake of the exercise,
do not attempt to review
this video, we will know.
I'm going to show you
some images of criminals
matching the description that
you gave the police earlier.
From these images I'd like you
to identify the man with the gun.
Can you do that for me?
(dramatic crime music)
So, think you know who it was?
Are you sure?
Are you positive?
Well, based on your eyewitness account
we were able to arrest
this man, Mike Carrier.
Thanks for your help.
(dramatic crime music)
(BuzzFeed sound effect)